Blake Lively talks baby number two and  gushes over her daughter James she's  very sweet he caught up with the 28 year  old actress on Tuesday in New York at  the premiere of her new movie the  shallows Blake opened up about her  two-year-old daughter James revealing  she's quite the fashionista just like  her mama you look unbelievable  what does James think of you when you're  all dressed up and looking so incredible  this she's very sweet she says wow very  complimentary and that means more to me  than any compliment she likes to get  dressed up - yeah she you know she likes  to get dressed up she likes to get messy  she likes to you know do all the things  I like later this year little James will  get a sibling  Blake is expecting baby number two with  husband Ryan Reynolds at Tess you look  amazing but how are you feeling is the  easier second time around how's it going  I feel good